the legendary Abbey Road Studios has
recorded countless musicians of all the
genres since its founding in 1931.
so from Stevie Wonder and sting to Amy
Winehouse and Tony Bennett and there's
so many more but it was made famous by
you know who the Beatles recorded most
of their music there so you may remember
they named an album after its location
well there's a new documentary I love
this title if these walls could sing
shares the story of the legendary
recording studio Through The Eyes of the
people who created the music there
here's a clip
I don't remember the first time I came
here
This Is Me In Studio 2 a photograph
taken by my mum who was a photographer
and was in a band with my dad
I want to tell the story of some of the
iconic recordings made here over the
last nine decades from classical to pop
to film scores
well the director is Mary McCartney you
know the name who's you just heard grew
up near the studio that her dad that
would be Sir Paul McCartney helped put
it on the map she's also listen to
Mary's credentials she's a renowned
photographer she's a cookbook author and
she's got her own cooking show Mary
McCartney you are not busy hello and
welcome thank you we're so glad that
you're here on our last day here live as
well yeah we're really glad to have you
been a good year for me this year has it
been a good year yeah I've enjoyed this
year it's gone fast but I've really
enjoyed it why do you say that yeah tell
us why well we are going to talk about
your documentary But first
you know the cooking show I had an
amazing exhibition photographic
exhibition in at Chateau Lacoste in
France and the documentary so
career-wise and everyone's getting back
together I'm here in real life I came on
before yeah you were you were in a zoo
I'm a chemistry person I like to see
people and yes us too us too so as we as
we get ready to close out 2022 and we're
talking about holiday traditions yes
what you all do you have did you all
have holiday traditions growing up with
fairies yeah we're very traditional we
do we do Christmas and so we all sort of
put the tree I mean we do a lot a lot of
fairy lights a lot of fairy lights a lot
of words the lights yeah so the tree is
not like those white lights arteries
like multi-colored lights all
decorations that we've collected over
the years we like to sort of go quite
big on the decorating is that when you
were growing up with with Poland yeah
with uh like literally I saw Dad last
weekend and everything is up even like
sort of little toys that you press that
sing Silly Songs New Year's Eve we'd
always go to Liverpool growing up you
know it's a big family feel so we would
go out 12 o'clock we'd be with the
family having a big house party all my
cousins and uncles and aunts and all
their friends I love them and then 12
o'clock we'd all go out into the street
and join arms and do Old Lang Syne
uh-huh I like that tradition you and
your dad ever cook together I know your
show Mary McCartney serves it up can
Paul McCartney cook he can cook but he
his job usually is to make the cocktail
he makes his macarita which you can see
it in the there's a celebration episode
on the cooking show where I cook
everything that we would have for a
traditional meal and here makes the
macarita and it's it's actually it was
so well filmed that when he came into
the kitchen and the lighting was all
nice and sort of festive yeah that we
were talking and then I looked in to
talk to the camera to talk to the viewer
and he was like oh yeah I forgot that's
when you know it's a good shoe so your
show is about hosting get togethers yeah
um and there's a lot of get together
this is going to happen now and moving
forward
um what are your biggest tips
biggest tips are I love to do things
per head because I like I don't want to
be stressed when I'm hanging out with
friends so prepare ahead I like simple
things but with quite a flavor impact
and
um shortcuts shortcuts we love that you
made no shortcuts with your documentary
Mary yeah you made nine thank you thank
you we were as a baby not much other
than the dust on the floor now that
you're grown up and a director and you
went through all these interviews and
all these archival footage what
surprised you the most
well first of all I didn't know it was
90 years
I mean all of it surprised me I I live
nearby so I see people crossing that
there's zebra zebra Crossing all the
time
um but I've gone in over the years to
visit people and working there I know
the people that were there but 90 years
is literally from 31 and it's a thriving
busy studio now so yeah Elton John I
mean some of it really I've sort of
scattered it there's a lot of beetles
because they recorded all their albums
at bar let it be but like Elton John was
a session musician there Jimmy Page from
Led Zeppelin so they're a great story it
really is such an iconic placement what
it must mean to your family yeah what
did your dad tell you about it growing
up what did you think well we used to
just go there because when the Beatles
broke up Wings would record there too
and this is his band yeah yeah and then
my mum was in the band as well I mean
one of the reasons that I've done this
documentary I was approached by the
producer and I have this memory a
picture of my mom leading a pony across
the zebra Crossing because she loved
animals so much
so I needed to do it because I was like
so literally we went there that much wow
she she went one day and was like let's
bring the pony it's kind of kind of
bizarre yeah Beatles music is great for
family get-togethers because like
everybody loves Beatles music uh it's
big in my household you guys ever listen
to The Beatles at home during the
holidays yeah yeah we do lots of
playlists we actually list to listen to
quite festive dad has a Christmas
playlist so we do that but always music
on please share dad's Christmas playlist
like growing up like we'd go to the
recording studio but growing up like
we'd be watching TV and he'd come in and
we'd be like he'd be playing something
we're like Dad could you like we're
watching TV
and he would say that you know I do it
with my kids saying that though you
can't get arrested around your kids so
you're sort of like do you know how many
people it's like can you go to their
house please
take that to the studio
thank you very much yeah and Happy here
that documentary happy New Years could
sing is out now on Disney Plus